[Music]
maybe the worst part though was his
laughter as he contorted himself to
where his torso was now outstretched
into the room with me and his arms were
wildly waving in my direction hello and
welcome to all daint a creepypasta
or her stories cooked to perfection with
a splash of red sauce my name is Susie
and I will be your server this episode
today's episode is a sequel to creepy
clown school lockdown which you can
click or tap right here to listen to if
you wish but you don't necessarily have
to watch them in order this time we're
moving up to high school I know many of
you don't look back at your high school
years too fondly but I think today's
offering will make you appreciate your
experience a little bit more let's dig
right in fourth period algebra was the
most dreaded part of my day not only do
I hate math but it's the last morning
class before lunch the schedule gets a
little easier once I hit that afternoon
home
but that hump is a big one I have never
been good with math and having MS Nelson
or as we call her the Crypt Keeper was
not making things easier this semester
in fact the only thing keeping me afloat
in that class was the fact that my
friend Chris was texting me the answers
from second period it was a muggy
afternoon towards the end of the school
year as usual mrs. Nelson refused to
turn on the air conditioning it was
somehow fitting to be broiling through
my fourth period hell we started the
Thursday exam and the Cryptkeeper
plopped behind her desk in the front
corner of the room cheating my way
through this would be easier than I
thought
I placed down a water bottle and slyly
slid my phone across the desk into the
bottle shadow piece of cake I opened my
texts conversation with Chris and began
to transfer the information onto the
page
is a be a twenty four point three
repeating I had to mix in a couple wrong
answers as well just to make it
believable
just then I hear the unmistakable sound
someone getting up from a chair my eyes
dart up and see the old pile of bones
rising to her feet crap
I wondered if she suspected something
she began to pace towards my desk
Just My Luck I guess I'd have to act
like I was actually trying to solve the
equations until she sat back down it was
like reading another language I had no
idea what I was doing that's when I
noticed my phone buzz I should have
turned off the vibration before the test
I don't think he gave me away though
could have been anyone's phone from
anyone's pocket but there was bad news
the vibration started sliding my phone
down the small incline of the desk it
slowly slid away from the safe cover of
the water bottle I glanced up to the
teacher
her eyes were locked onto me the phone
continued to slide down all I could do
was hope that it stopped or that she
turned away long enough for me to slip
the phone in my pocket no such luck and
fell off the desk and onto the floor
trying to play it off like it had fallen
out of my pocket I reached down to grab
the phone but a cold bony hand grasped
my wrist before I could office now and
those were the only words that came out
of her mouth at least it was
air-conditioned in the area outside the
dean's office where I sat to await my
sentencing the dean's office was a
smaller room within the confines of the
main office which basically connects all
the offices of the administration who
were supposedly all out at lunch so I'd
have to wait for the Dean to return
before I would find out how long I'd be
spending in detention you can imagine my
surprise when a fully costumed circus
clown dragging a big hammer walked into
the room with me that seemed odd I
hadn't heard of any assemblies or
anything going on this week I'm not
exactly sure when I had the realization
that something foul was up with this
clown it wasn't when he grabbed a chair
and shoved it under the main door of the
office to jam it shut I just saw that as
more of a gag
to get me to crack a smile for some
reason I guess when it started to get
uncomfortable it was when he dragged his
hammer across the desks in the middle of
the office knocking over a bunch of
stuff and making a mess with me and
giggling maniacally still I just had no
reason to get too freaked out any
further than a little bit of nervous
laughter I mean for all I knew the
school's admin could have just been
pranking each other no I don't think it
was until I saw the clown starting to
talk to himself when the panic started
to set in step right up and test your
might then he swung the hammer in the
air high over his head and Orton smashed
it down and doorknob to the principal's
Prophets the door was basically
destroyed and swung right open then the
clown looked at me dead in the eyes and
said looks like we have a winner
then he trudged into the principal's
office I was frozen in fear at this
point not sure if I should run for it
and find someone or if I was on a
hidden-camera show or what the hell was
going on meanwhile the clown was
rummaging around in the principal's
office when I heard a loud crack come
from the school's intercom system
followed by the sound of analog feedback
it went on for a few seconds before
being replaced by
circus music but it sounded creepy in
that stuff
I think you'd blown out a speaker on the
intercom I also felt the air conditioner
come to a halt and if I wasn't mistaken
it had been replaced with heat the
clown's side shuffled out of the
principal's office with the hammer slung
over his shoulder and the most evil
looking sinister grin what was shocking
about his appearance was how wide his
smile spread it looked like his grin
nearly stretched from ear to ear and I
mean that literally
that and the glowing look in his eyes
told me that I needed to bolt right now
I sprang out of my chair just as the
clown screeched and charged at me I
slipped into the dean's office before he
could get to me slam the door and he
locked it I knew that wouldn't cover me
for long now so I immediately ones the
desk and tried to push it in front of
the door
it was much heavier than it looks I
couldn't get the thing to budge the
bookshelf would have to do for now but I
knew I was only biding my time I felt
the crash of the hammers impact attacked
the door as I positioned the bookshelf
it not only knocked the doorknob off but
smashed the wood in that area all around
the doorknob letting in a beam of light
through the outside that light soon
became blotted out by the clown's huge
yellow smile staring at me through the
hole he began the cackle I didn't know
how long I had I instinctively reached
my phone to try to call for help but
my heart lunge as I realized that it had
been confiscated by mrs. Nelson I looked
around the tiny office there was a phone
on the desk a landline I picked it up
punch 9-1-1 but as soon as I brought it
to my ear all I got was signal the line
had somehow been disconnected with no
window in the room I had no means of
escape and with the main office door
barricaded I was trapped in here with
this this maniac then I realized he was
no longer staring through the hole he
was going to try to ram it in again I
felt my eyes well up with tears as I
started to realise all the possibilities
of what he might do to me with one
last-ditch effort I grunted and pushed
the dean's desk as hard as I could and
managed to tip it over sending it
slamming to the ground the picture of
the Dean's daughter shattered on the
floor but there was no time to worry
about the repercussions of that now the
door was starting to open and I was able
to drive the desk just far enough to
stop the clown from getting in I
struggled to push the desk a few moments
more and it seemed like we're at a
stalemate then it seemed like he had
stopped pushing in the sound of the
circus music abruptly stopped and as far
as I could tell the clown had given up
then out of nowhere
through the partially open and partially
busted door the collage himself into the
opening and tried to squeeze himself
through I screamed when I saw the circus
makeup melting off his face like some
kind of nightmarish monk painting his
once round with puffy
wig was now drenched in sweat and stuck
to his face for a series of dark red
strands maybe the worst part though was
his laughter is he can't ordered himself
to wear his torso was now outstretched
into the rock with me and his arms were
wildly waving in my direction
instinctively I jumped back which was a
bad idea because he was then able to
retract back to the other side of what
was left of the door and slowly but
surely force it open in my direction at
this point he'd surely get in all I
could do was prepare myself to fight a
battle I knew I could not win then out
of nowhere his progress just stopped
this time I didn't let down my guard I
stood on high alert when I noticed some
banging around in the background someone
was trying to get into the office
suddenly I could see the light at the
end of the tunnel and I hoped that I
might be saved the main office door was
kicked down and the voice of the school
police officer yelled out freeze get
your hands in the air I have to admit it
didn't sound very convincing given that
I could hear the tremble in his voice
but I was at least somewhat comforted
knowing that he'd be armed I called out
for help and the officer rushed to my
aid the strange part was the clown was
nowhere to be found I explained that he
had smashed the door in moments before
but in searching the entire office we
couldn't figure out how he had gotten
away in fact there were only two pieces
of evidence that ended up being found
one was a rubber clown nose left clamped
to the microphone in the principal's
office that was hooked up to the
school's PA system the other was a nod
of red hair from the clown's wig I would
later find out that they ran tests on it
and discovered that it was real human
hair
it belonged to this guy Bronson who was
currently in prison serving a 15 year
sentence there was no way he could have
escaped so the appearance of his DNA
only added to the mystery I wish I could
say it ended there with me getting out
of my punishments on account of the
traumatic experience but there was one
more haunting thing
that happened while it was true that I
didn't have to serve my detention I
think it's safe to say that I learned my
lesson and I was never going to cheat on
another test again or do anything that
might get my phone confiscated for that
matter I was able to scratch by and pass
math with the D my parents weren't happy
about it but again I got a little
sympathy after having nearly become the
jesters afternoon snack or whatever so
summer came and I was free for a couple
more months Chris and I were
skateboarding on the street towards
7-eleven and I heard a strange sound and
stopped what's wrong Chris asked me I
held up an index finger I listened for a
moment and I was sure I can make out the
sound of the same circus music from that
day in the office I looked up to find
the car it was coming from a beat-up red
bug with no license plates my eyes met
the drivers it was the very same clown
from before again with the makeup melted
down his face onto his collar in a most
disturbing manner in world of them
yeah thanks for listening to all Dane
Dane creepypasta your total today is 24
dollars and 33 cents but if you like
this video right now I'll waive that fee
and give you everything you just listen
to absolutely free this episode score
was done by the talented OST maker and
the end theme you're hearing now is
naolia Sakamoto's rendition of
Beethoven's moonlight sonata head into
the comments and let me know of any
other stories you'd like to see get a
sequel every like in comment helps out
the channel but if you want to float to
it you'll have to pick up one of these
shirts from the merch store remember to
subscribe the Seas E's world for new
Horrors every week ring that death bell
until it says all notifications and I'll
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive
[Music]